from a team perspective um it's just the
fit do you complement each other I I as
I said before think that you should
build a company with people that you
consider better than you in different
areas and you're very complimentary in
terms of how you're going to build it's
going to be a long path with a lot of
ups and downs and you need to figure out
that the your co-founders both
compliment you and personally and
professionally there going to be a lot
of issues a lot of good days a lot of
bad days that you can continue
persevering enduring during the during
that time and from an idea
perspective look the ideas are diamond
dozen you need to be passionate about
what you're
building you need to understand that
you're solving a real problem and
ideally you need to encounter that
problem firsthand to understand what is
the true impact of both the problem how
it stands now and the solution that
you're offering
[Music]
Michael nov welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here with me
how are you I'm wonderful how are you uh
this uh cold morning in New York I'm I'm
doing great from a not so cold afternoon
here in Tel Aviv
so the sun is coming down I'm looking at
the ocean it's the perfect setting to
talk about startups security by from the
design stage and and your own Journey so
Michael H we'll dive straight into it
you know before we get into uh Prime
security tell me a little bit about your
own background how do you get to today
if you look at the big pillars of your
journey wow uh quite diverse background
I'm a double immigrant so born in Russia
moved to Israel when it was for kind of
the first Aliah uh for those that are
familiar with it spent my formative
years of my career in the Israeli Army
uh I did the equivalent of West Point
ATA program so went to went to college
before going to the Army and then spend
six years as an officer focus on from on
fpna out of all
things knew that I wanted to spend some
time in the US so transitioned via
business school went to Duke if you're a
basketball fan then go Blue Devils a
fantastic year thus far and then after
that spend a Deca decade in Enterprise
software first I'm Consulting uh started
working at deit spent five years there
working on specifically with private
equities on caral stand-ups which is a
niche of a niche of a niche uh
supporting technology companies how to
build a net new business out of a
business unit super interesting work
teaches you a lot about operational
excellence and how to you should think
about businesses uh in general and
always knew that I wanted to be an
entrepreneur uh I had a bunch of
entrepreneurial Ventures when I was much
younger in my in my career so kind of
pre- Army and embarked on my first
Venture with a few good friends friend
we started building a B2B SAS platform
for large events unfortunately we
started building that in Co just before
covid and then covid hit so our business
kind of pretty much died and out of that
I joined a company called own backup I
joined very early on um a backup and
Recovery company out of all things not
the sexiest area but uh an area that I
saw a huge potential the company was
doing very well and seems like a product
that's very needed uh the hypothesis was
simple SAS products need backup and
Recovery as well not only Cloud
environments just because they hold so
much of your critical business critical
information I joined first to build the
corporate development arm uh which was
classic
m&a and my role evoled very
quickly and at scale after spending four
years there I played multiple roles uh
predominantly led the build by partner
motion how do we deliver more
capabilities to our customers so I
bought through company's partner was
industry industry leaders and build two
new products um and the second thing I
was the right-and person to our CTO and
kind of that's where I met the problem
and I can elaborate on that a little bit
later um and a year ago after meeting
the problem firsthand decided to leave
with three good friends of mine uh to
build Prime security so walk me through
first of all awesome Journey really cool
from the h upbringing ER and immigration
to the to the military and fpna
interesting yeah curious how that what
lessons are learned there but maybe
we'll leave that for for another episode
but uh you know getting into obviously
Consulting and and um and then in the
backup and I got to know own backup
story quite intimately as well which is
a quite a phenomenal company obviously a
very phenomenal um outcome uh just
recently getting acquired 1.9 billion I
believe cash to Sal 2.1 2.1 so Ju Just a
$200 million
difference peanuts of course's friends
exactly ER and um and so today Prime
security what stage are you in in your
life and career when you think about
embarking on this entrepreneurial
Journey with two friends the cyber
security Journey ER which of all things
which is not so
trivial you know I I don't think there's
a right place in your career to Embark
of that on on a journey of
Entrepreneurship I think for each person
it's going to be being ready whenever
they are ready I think the most critical
part for me was building a company with
people I wanted to build a company with
people that I consider better than me in
different areas so on my end I waited
until I had both the right team and we
had the right idea and from a team
perspective perspective I I was very
fortunate to work with two of my
co-founders at own so we uh came out of
own together and the fourth one Dimitri
he was um security operator for years
and a good friends for good friend for
years and he's also considering an Ural
Journey so it just made sense for us to
partner and to build Prime
together yeah and so when you think
through how to you know when the the
questions of evaluating the idea and the
team when you're ready
what signals did you have knowing that
you're
ready from a team perspective um it's
just the fit do you complement each
other I I as I said before think that
you should build a company with people
that you consider better than you in
different areas and you're very
complimentary in terms of how you're
going to build it's going to be a long
path with a lot of ups and downs and you
need to figure out that the your
co-founders both compliment you and
personally and professionally
there are going to be a lot of issues a
lot of good days a lot of bad days that
you can continue persevering enduring
during the during that time and from an
idea
perspective look the ideas are dime it
doesn't you need to be passionate about
what you're
building you need to understand that
you're solving a real problem and
ideally you need to encounter that
problem firsthand to understand what is
the true impact of both the problem how
it stands now and the solution you're
offering and so how did these three
elements uh come into play for you with
prime security yeah team well two of my
co-founders we worked together for close
to three years we knew that we're a good
fit we were good friends very early on
when they joined on backup VN
acquisition actually that's how I got to
know them early on and the third one
well one of my our my co-founders knew
him personally from a previous life and
work together and when they joined own
he introduced us because well we were
both ex Soviet Union Israelis living in
New York around the same age he just
said you guys should be friends and we
became friends to the process so when
this opportunity present itself that for
all of us to work together it was a
no-brainer now from a problem
perspective again we arrived to it from
two different sides I encountered the
problem of lacking security at the
design stage at own
I part of my role was buying security
tools and I had everything under the sun
I bought every security tool to secure
application because security was
Paramount for us we stored insecure data
for some of the biggest customers
biggest organizations in the world we
had to be secure but that friction
between security teams and Engineering
teams was always there and the reason
for that was at the design stage at the
Inception of an idea or a change to a
product all security work was
manual and that friction was always
there causing us to miss a lot of
product deadlines and not delivering
product in
time and as Kevin y says there got to be
a better way so we started thinking what
could be the better
way while Dimitri used to be work used
to work at PayPal where he led security
architecture and thre modeling teams
they're reporting to the SE to the
ciso he saw the same problem on his end
as an operator saying well I cannot
support 9,000 developers there's no way
for me to manually do that that was two
years a year and a half ago and C GPT
emerg into the
scene how can you take that new
technology and apply it to a process
that is based all on instructure data
all on ideation of how to build what to
build in terms of a product so we came
to the same conclusion of there got to
be a better way here you got to do
something differently to enable this
from both the business Direction and the
security
direction to us it was a perfect
fit so walk through the the the product
or the the the vision for the
product what it really is prime security
all
about prime security is about product
security we see that product security
has to start in the Inception of the
product when you start ideating on what
you're going to build what you're going
to change in the
future we provide Three core
capabilities to our customers one we
scan your entire environment and allow
you to identify when security teams are
needed when do they actually need to
intervene in an engineering work and to
provide engineering with guidance how to
build securely and we do it with deep
and immediate integration with platforms
like jira confluence or G
drive that prevents security teams from
chasing after engineers and asking the
like hey what are you building is it
going to be built securely or Waiting
For Engineers to come to them and tell
them hey I need your guidance here
that's friction causes a lot of
incidents and balloons later mediations
and pentest reports the second thing is
what L do really well is
contextualization we aggregate all this
information cont contextualize every
task for the security professional
surfacing both business and security
risks for the team security teams
usually call it J tabell where they used
going from ticket ticket to tickets to
the design trying to understand what the
heck is engineer trying to achieve here
because there one security person
usually for 100 engineers and it's very
hard to dig deep into every single
engineering task review it and provide
good feedback to the
engineers so Iden ify the risk we
contextualize it well now let's drive it
to
remediation so provide and and build
custom
recommendations based on industry best
practices or the policies that the
customer follow for every risk and allow
the security team to provide that to the
engineer with a click of a
button in our case is writing it back to
the engineering workflow which is in
most cases is it CH and so from the
security perspect from the ciso
perspective if you actually look in and
we dive a little bit deeper into the
value proposition for them how much are
they do they care about the value
proposition of the the sort of the the
frictionless engagement where you're the
you're the broker if you will between
the engineering work and the security
and the decision of a security teams to
uh to jump in and and and lend their
hand versus ident versus doing the cont
the
contextualization and and helping
identify and do the remediation yourself
where do you see the bigger value
proposition
here business velocity is everything in
today's world for software enabl
companies above a certain scale which we
find around 100
Engineers Building Products securely and
quickly is extremely
important and what we're solving is a
process that's done everywhere but it's
done manually and it scales also
manually so many security
teams decide to well are structure the
process and continue throwing resources
or in many cases deal with the outcomes
or and playing wacka identifying those
issues in pentests identify those issues
in Productions which pushes development
road maps backwards every time because
you're asking developers to go back and
remediate those issues before sending
them back to before sending the product
production we add scale to the process
we allow you to manage the risks at
scale and extremely efficiently without
adding
headcount if you think about the promise
of new new AI Technologies this is
essentially what you can achieve with
newer AI Technologies you can scale
extremely manual processes that are
based on structured data something that
was not never been done before in our
case so what we see is a lot of very
very positive feedback and a lot of
adoption in today
today wow so effectively if if you're
looking at this the space down the line
en Envision for me what the world looks
like in your eyes let's say uh two to
three years from now in the context of
what you're saying so obviously AI is
changing extremely quickly what what do
you see possible in two to three
years okay you're you're also running AI
company that a lot so a lot of things
are possible in in your in your world of
course in the world of of of the llms
the and the and the different things
you're able to do with the security by
Design in my world I see a lot of skill
in for product security
teams they need to add head count and
continue growing your security team
while development velocity is going to
grow is going to get slower and slower
product security Engineers which just
get superpowers with new AI enabled
tooling superpower that will allow them
to identify risk faster and to resolve
them much faster and much earlier in the
life cycle of development is the do you
think that there's going to be a market
expectation or some sort of table Stakes
environment where this idea that
Engineers will will behave or will
program with security inherently is part
of the the Engineering Process that'll
be sort of a a common methodology across
Enterprises I believe so um we need to
Define what an engineer will be
engineering is also changing as as we
speak AI agents are optimizing
engineering as well and producing more
and more features and more and more code
much much faster than before that's
going to continue adding pressure and
security to review all of it because
nothing is going to be perfect out of
the box if we look at the the modern AI
coding tools they are not yet security
adapt out of the box and even when they
will be security adapt from a code
perspective they're not necessarily
going to be adapt from a design
perspective because understanding the
design of the software requires deeply
understanding the environment that
you're designing the software
and that's where Prime will come into
play we will provide the guidance of how
to build the software securely not just
from a code perspective but from a
design perspective and do it at
exception
absolutely what do you think are the
biggest challenges are going to be um in
your category for Prime security over
the coming years Ai and Adoption of AI
is always challenging a lot of enterpris
are hesitant to adopt AI at full scale
there's reliability issues there
security issues there and trust issues
in general those issues will be overcome
with time we need to prove ourselves and
AI tools need to prove themselves in
general that they can be reliable and
efficient and deliver on the pris that
we have right and how do you find ways
to mitigate that with the Enterprise
so you know is it is it just a matter of
time is it a matter of you know maturity
for the technology are the things that
you can you see are effective as an
entrepreneur that you can do in helping
bridge that Gap because obviously you
you know it's our job as entrepreneurs
to bridge that gap of course uh number
one build securely from the GetGo um we
are a very security minded and security
oriented team that has built security
products before so for us building
security into the product is extremely
important we started from that secondly
reliability um we all speak about AI
hallucinations how can you prevent those
from happening and we take it on upon us
to prevent it as much as possible but
doing Ro embedding robust QA and
automated QA in to our processes so that
the output that the customer sees might
be more expensive for us because we have
to in this case run anms multiple times
to make sure that the answer is
consistent so we take the cost but
provide the best output to our
customers makes a ton of sense Michael
what and that will be optimized with
time too we see the LMS improving
exponentially so we see this as a
temporary
issue yeah and uh I think yeah I think
that's part part of the exciting areas
of riding the riding the wave and being
able to enjoy the fruits of of how the
industry is adapting to to the to the
emerging Technologies Michael H if you
look at the this journey and in general
and you look also the the up in the next
phases of the journey what are you most
excited
about building a fantastic company with
fantastic people and delivering True
Value to
customers it's also so it's it's always
incredible to hear when you are actually
being able to drive change and positive
change in Impact with customers that's
what gets me up in the morning that's
what gets me excited and doing that with
good friends and a phenomenal team that
we built at Prime is is a joy that's
when work becomes fun not just
work love Michael best of luck with
prime security sounds like a very very
cool Journey sounds like a cool area to
be in today
and uh one that definitely helps
integrate the way that AI is changing
the landscape of of of security and
bringing security more inherently is
part of the day-to-day of the
organization so thank you very much
absolutely thank you for having me
Michael thank you